okay so the center just posted a new
video of tom cruise going into a
complete meltdown
over mission impossible seven crew
members not following covert 19 safety
protocols
we're gonna play the clip in just a bit
but as we go through it i'd of course
love to hear your thoughts on it
if you think he was right and then at
the end of the video i'll go into my
thoughts and
why i think he was if this is your first
time here then welcome to the heavy
spoilers show
i'm your host paul now let's get into
this clip
they're back here in hollywood making
movies right now because of
us because they believe in us
and what we're doing i'm on the phone
with every
studio at night insurance companies
producers and they're looking at
us and using us to make their movies
we are creating thousands of jobs
i don't ever want to see it again ever
and if you don't do it you're fired and
i see you do it again you're
gone and anyone on this crew does it
that's it and you do and you too
and you if you ever do it again
that's it no apologies
you can tell it to the people that are
losing their own
because our industry is shut down it's
not going to put food on their table
or pay for their college education
so i'm sorry i'm beyond your apologies i
have told you
and now i want it and if you don't do it
you're out
we are not shutting this movie down
is it understood if i see it again
you're
going and sure you so you're gonna cost
him his job
and i see on the set you're going and
you're going
that's it am i clear do you
understand what i want you understand
the responsibility that you have
because i will deal with your reason and
if you can't be reasonable
and i can't deal with your logic you're
fired
that's it that is it
i trust you guys to be here
that's it
okay so lots of things to talk about
there um
when i think of tom cruise i think of
some guy smiling grinning away
doing the gun fingers going papa pow you
know he's always excited
he's always running somewhere and to
hear this it just completely juxtaposes
what i think of him
but i think because of that you know
these guys must have been messing around
quite a lot
now we don't know exactly what's going
on on set and take this with a pinch of
salt
but from what was said and what i've
read it seems like they weren't wearing
masks
tom cruise is a very strict uncovered
rules and from what he says in the
speech he obviously talks a lot with
producers every night
insurance companies and people in the
movie industry to make sure that
everything is going to go ahead tom is
very passionate about this film
and he can sort of feel that coming
through now a lot of people are saying
he's a diva
like you shouldn't talk to people like
that in general just
you need to be nice to people but
sometimes yeah
you've just got to tell people this
probably isn't the first time he's had
to do this and
obviously it's going to make tensions
rise if people are just constantly
breaking the rules
and he's letting it go and checked i'm
guessing that it was very serious for
the main actor in this massive franchise
to come and say
look i'm telling you now and yeah
these guys must have felt very very
small i feel like this is
the speech that parents give after they
do that i'm not mad
i'm just disappointed one you if you
don't listen to that yeah
your parents bring out tom cruise and he
completely shuts you down
now it sounds like these people actually
needed a dressing down and the things
that he goes into in this speech are of
course very serious
there's people losing their jobs because
of this the industry has pretty much
came to a standstill
and you know it's had a massive effect
on the cinema industry
and pretty much ruined a lot of the
economy so
tom doesn't want anything like that to
happen and he's gonna do whatever he can
to make sure that it doesn't
this guy is doing the most impossible
mission in the world right now
which is to stop people being an idiot
in the pandemic
now when the outbreaks first happened i
thought oh you know
finally we've got this thing that's
going to bring everyone together we can
all form a united front and fight this
thing as humanity combined
however that hasn't been the case and
there's been a lot of division over the
last year
over how to handle it and people are
just going with
crazy conspiracy theories all the time
and yeah it's
it's quite annoying to see now i'm not
gonna go down the rabbit hole of
shouting at you and giving you a telling
off
but you know tom tom's got his stance
here he's made it very clear i imagine
when they started the movie that
you can't be doing this stuff and people
just aren't paying attention
a lot of people are comparing this to
the christian bale run from a couple of
years ago but that was over some
lightning and a guy walking around
in the background of a set whereas here
you know people's lives and jobs are at
risk
so i don't blame the guy at all i think
he's in the right
and i think he's talking to the world i
think this message needs to get out
there because there's a lot of people in
political power that are letting down
the world
and we just need someone to come forward
and say
look this is costing people their lives
it's costing people their jobs
people cannot put food on their table
because of what you're doing
so yeah completely fair and you know
what else i like about tom he didn't
fire him
he said look this is your warning if you
do it again
it's going to cost you your job and it's
going to cost him your job
the other guy probably just standing
there like oh man i was just standing
where my mask and this guy came over and
started talking to me
but you know he's been brought into it
too so not nice to hear
but you know this is this is a massive
production people want to see mission
impossible seven
the guy's doing an impossible mission
right now and speaking to the world
now on top of this he also clearly has
reasons for doing it because
mission impossible 7 was actually
recently hit with delays
in october as 12 people on set tested
positive for covid
this happened in italy and no production
managed to resume a week later
it's clearly marred a lot of the
experience for the cast and crew
they're currently filming in the uk
which i live in at the moment and you
can sort of see that people just aren't
paying attention to things
even when they're being asked nicely so
you just have to say
look here listen to tom he's trying to
help you and help other people
which i think is fair enough now the
movie is due to release on november 19
2021
so it is quite a strict deadline to get
this all finished
i'm totally on tom's side with this but
obviously i know people are going to
disagree with me and this isn't a
channel where i'm like
well i'm i'm right and you're wrong so
you either agree with me or you get
blocked
if you disagree yet that's totally fine
and make sure you leave your thoughts in
the comment section below as
i'm sure this is gonna cause a lot of
discussion now if you enjoy this video
then please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for videos like this every day
we're actually giving away three free
copies of the lord of the rings 4k box
set to our followers
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop your thoughts
on it in the comment section below
anyway a bit more of a fun thing to talk
about we've just done a massive loki
trailer breakdown which is going to be
linked on screen right now
so if you want something else to watch
give that a click and i'll love you
forever
thanks for sitting with me until the end
of the video i've been paul
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care peace